I became a musician because I couldn't
do anything else because like I think
all musicians making music was the way
that I make sense with the world
I have no description for my creative
process I have no idea how it works
except to just try and be available and
vulnerable to what's happening with me
in life and just kind of it has more to
do to sort of relaxing into it than
anything else and I also I think create
a creative process happens when you're
not in a state of judgment about
yourself you're in this kind of like
you're not editing you're just kind of
expressing without without any kind of
recrimination which is kind of hard to
do since most artists are engaging quite
a bit of self-hate myself included
I had a lot of ups and downs in my whole
pedagogy I have some learning
impediments I have a DD and I have
dyslexia and that made it very hard for
me to function in the institution of
school so I failed the first grade but I
also managed to go to Cal Berkeley and I
studied English there and I think there
I learned two things from studying
literature one was I learned how to pay
attention to what I was thinking to what
was happening in my own mind and I also
learned how to edit to say this is this
is the cookie cutter of my thoughts
these are the things that fit in and
these are the things that don't I think
a lot of my education happened in the
music business itself we're now in a new
music music business the the old style
the major-label records is is in the
process of ending it's not over yet and
certainly they are still relevant but
they are changing into something else
if they weren't changing a group like
big think would not be doing an
interview with me we would there
wouldn't be anything to talk about so
what we're talking about is the change I
think my education says a student is
just about sort of being collegial with
people and learning senses of balance
but I probably learned that as much in
in in the process of having a a band
with a record deal in dealing with
marketers and radio promotions people
and publicists etc
you